how do we find a world in which we can
feel like we are enough and maintain our
drive and go forward people running away
from insufficiency as opposed to running
towards something that they want because
the implication of that is that in order
to be successful you need to have fear
you need to have insufficiency you go
well I don't want that when I want the
success but I don't want the
insufficiency so okay like how do I
balance these two I think habit has an
awful lot to account for here the
activation energy that a lot of people
have is pain and desire to prove the
world wrong or to prove themselves to be
sufficient to the world and that will
get you going and after a while if you
do something for long enough that's just
what you do it's like someone who's
starting going to the gym and training
versus you you're going to the gym now
but the reason that you go now is
because of habits I do think that there
are ways that you can work on getting
rid of the trauma whilst holding on to
the drive for Success next question is
what are you optimizing for am I
optimizing for just being as successful
as possible or am I optimizing for an
enjoyable life and an enjoyable life
would include being successful but it
would also probably include not being
filled with crippling insufficiency all
the time so this is a more important
question